okay let's get this ball rolling d4 hit
him what a trump popskyy black is
officially been Trump pops cubed 94
now what night here I'm gonna play
Bishop f4
Chapa night
no trades No
I have no idea about the theory on this
and I really just want to run all the
way home can I run home let me yeah
actually let me run all the way home
doing this because I figured Queen b6 is
going to be played anyhow I want to just
chase this night away challenge it in
some way if I'm d6 I can't play f3 but
if d6 isn't played I could be
considering this d6 f3 excuse me now
what am I talking about
well if ecigs is played in the Queen as
this square available then this is not a
good idea but now now it's it's worth
considering so should I challenge the
night with my knight or do I kick it
away the answer is kick it away do you
know why because I have a space
advantage and I don't want to be trading
pieces there so
let's do this I'm going to challenge
that Bishop there we go and let's get my
night out I don't want to obstruct my up
I want to stop I want to stop b5 I
didn't want to strike my bishop that's
why I've develop my night to d2 and how
do I complete my development
hmm
ah I need to find a better setup maybe
night seat maybe eight yeah okay wait a
five my opponent castles I could
consider a five but I am lacking in
development here let me play Bishop out
reinforce this deter this advance I have
to be content with giving up my bishop
um so now what maybe kick this Knight
right now make a decision night okay so
I'm just there in time to recapture
excuse me that was that's what happens
when you eat a granola bar too soon oh
man I need to be burped
okay let's castle
and now Knight c4 he's going to fall in
love with c4 c4 to b6 maybe it's
worthwhile to do this move so I could
you know stops my knight from playing
there if I play c4 the bishop comes back
and says well kind of just laughs at my
knight it's kind of saying okay Bishop
b5 c4 haha you will not be making use of
c4 to get to b6 but now the dark square
bishop czar off the board my knight is
excited about hitting d6 b6 my rook is
gonna come to be one let's come here c4
c4 be very scared there might be Bishop
takes Knight
um this pond could be past this pond
could be past right here e5 gotta be
good how can I be so assure so assure I
could I be so assured of that
this Knight is getting excited about
getting to d4 no I don't want you in my
territory no soup for you on d4 okay so
the follow-up plan okay now I have the F
file opened up and my knight has to be
incredibly annoying to team black right
here that I mean there are even
possibilities to just smash open the
Kings side just take the knight but this
is difficult to deal with now pawn push
should be avoided because I have an
unprotected Queen Knight takes or queen
takes is available in fact it has to be
queen takes if pomme push knight takes I
could actually take and then I'd be on
the Queen next so rook here is the way
to defend my night watches over this I
think I just want to push the night away
and if Knight back here to hit this pond
then I play here as soon as I'm stopping
the knight from playing here I'm gonna
go with this g4 he's got to go get out
of there
you need to go so decision time for the
Black Knight he doesn't have very many
choices be seven h6h for i guess this is
the most annoying one
I don't know
okay now actually the night is dead to
the game this pond boxes out the night
my rook could pivot on this f6 square
but I probably just want to do what I
probably just want to
look here to e3
just reinforce this there's only three
attackers that could ever be placed on
this pond actually doubling rooks
doesn't even work there's this night is
too too strong I mean there's even okay
now the queen is getting excited about
getting to this square so let's stop
that I don't I don't want her to get
here oh now I could maybe get this pawn
actually rook f4 grab here and it's dead
this is a sensitive point and I want to
just maintain that Jeep on right there
if I maintain my g4 pond I control the
night that's as far as I'm taking it
maintain g4 you control the night now if
pawn push then okay both our kings are
without a home I do have a connected
passed pawns now because of that last
push so I could just think about pushing
here very very soon less than 32 figure
it out this is much too difficult so
what's the plan I'm just looking to I'm
just trying to control the key squares
here taking into account my opponent's
piece activity and now that there's less
pressure on this point I could probably
just come over here double and actually
I could recapture with my queen knowing
that it would lead to may if the Queen
grabs here check and then mate is what
would occur if the Queen took on that
square now there is a check here but
actually just pawn push rook here is
threatened or Queen here is threatened
I'm in check just sidestep that this is
still a mate threat if the Queen goes
astray
oh man I'm actually seeing a smooth move
here I think do you see it huh I don't
know if I've ever seen a combination
like this Queen f7 is actually most
accurate Queen f7 it works out the King
goes in the corner it's me now rook
takes pawn if the King goes in the
corner its mate and if the King goes
here
then there's a fork
that's it actually I could clean next I
got the Queen get a queen and then take
a queen or something but it didn't um
didn't matter I'm at that time that's
you know just a matter of taste type of
thing um good game let me back up I
don't know that I shouldn't have gotten
uh oh
let's see know what I could really add
here
I wonder if well I wonder if something
like e 6 is mz6 a good idea no okay I
mean D 6 is still good it's though it's
like a Benko and I think there might
have been some opportunities to like
sack a sack and night or something like
my bishops unprotected and then like get
to this square a fork on e3 I've seen
that show up because I have played this
recently against pretty a GM and I think
there was something that was a
possibility at one point when I was
playing against that without guy but
where is there an improvement here I
wonder if okay night their night here
ISA 'kz how about this how about this
right here's the improvement because
right now if you take my bishop I think
things are really good for me
wait a second right here this is what I
was talking about actually look at this
look at this Knight takes d5 Bishop
takes Bishop Knight III in between move
although this ya know 93 in between move
queen c1 King takes bishop and then
actually King f2 the knight is actually
out of squares hmm follow that one
Knight takes pawn Bishop takes Bishop
Knight there's no recapture right away
Knight takes pawn Bishop takes Bishop
Knight III hitting my queen queen let's
say to c1 now King takes Bishop and the
threat of Knight takes pawn could be met
with King F to counter-attack defense
and attack I don't know if there's a
good solution I'll maybe Queen to g5 is
a move then but then I think Knight f1
and then the knight that the knight
would be in a pin in some way
okay anyhow it's something to be very
aware of the unprotected piece is
leading to tactics right here that
something there's this is a sensitive
point right here in fact as soon as I'd
make this move right here you could you
could be thinking about these ideas as
soon as I played this f3 say to yourself
you know what okay III is going to be a
soft point if the darker bishops are
ever off the board then you know maybe
maybe getting to that square can be
quite good so keep a close eye on that
particular square and the possibilities
that might come about so
maybe instead of castle consider a six
right now if my bishop gets to see four
then it's difficult to get this move in
so I wonder if just switching the order
don't castle just yet
play e6 yeah give give that a shot d6
this could become an issue but um maybe
you could just start pushing me around
or actually pop push takes takes Knight
d6 yeah that's that's no good so what is
there an improvement for black I mean
there's there's no way this could be
like great for y-you can it I am
reducing the pressure that this Bishop
would normally have in a Benko position
by being on this diagonal already a six
a four Castle trying to find improvement
I'm not quite sure where where it exists
um having a tough time here
c4 just seen it maybe Knight here is an
alternative yeah okay how about how
about ninety five really don't want to
give up my bishop if I ever take
recapture the knight could play to e8
and then d6 classic blockade so maybe
that maybe night right here because I
can't force the situation so quickly
into this Knight this Knight takes
bishop that's a big difference
you go to b6 I could force this I could
force things I could play a5 input and
you know your knight has to do something
right away however if your night is on
e5 I really don't want to take it and if
I'm playing f4 well that's not without
allowing this g4 square to be made
available for both your bishop and night
so maybe just switching the the square
that your knight posted to would be an
improvement here Knight to e5
would probably be my best suggestion at
this point again I don't have any
analysis no no no computer whatever
analysis going on and just some rough
thoughts here okay um let me close out I
got to be too much when the night was on
v6 this is uh this turns out to be a
positional crush there's because the
pond this pond negates two ponds and
it's like I'm I'm playing one two three
four five a six on five this pond takes
out these two and it's a six on five on
all the other files my knight has a
really strong post on v6 good decision I
believe by the way to take out by night
I really do think that that is a good
idea because otherwise see for the
bishop has to come back it doesn't have
much of a future so making sure to get
rid of the night before reacting I think
was uh some good awareness on my
opponents part so okay and maybe I guess
at this point instead the rook move
maybe just take don't allow me to to
guard to have two pawns side by side on
the d5 be five squares maybe take Queen
takes and then rip there or something
hope for the best but it's difficult I
could play back here something maybe was
your best try I think Pond takes Queen
takes and then go from there but this is
this is a tough guy right here